[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS LAW: All
right, hi, everybody.
My name is Chris.
I'm a product manager on
our Cloud Security team,
and I'm here today with Michael
Capicotto from Two Sigma,
where he's a Cloud
security architect.
And I'm here also with
Marten van Wezel, who's
a product manager on Forseti.
And I'm excited to talk to
you about security compliance
monitoring and how you
can do that with Forseti.
So if we step back,
Forseti's mission
is really to help get the
security community mobilized
around filling gaps for
Google Cloud Platform.
We do that by creating tools
and sharing best practices
that everybody on GCP can use.
We know that every
company has its own way
of thinking about security
threats and needs.
Forseti allows
you, as a customer,
to build upon the
security framework in GCP
and really close that
gap in the last mile
so that you're covered the
way that you want to be.
Together, we can all be safer.
When we move to Cloud, it's
really a cultural shift.
It allows everybody in your
organization to move faster.
That can make a lot
of people nervous,
because sometimes
people make mistakes.
What we want to make
sure that we can do--
and it's the core
use case of Forseti--
is really to allow your security
teams to create guardrails
for people as they're
doing their development so
that if a mistake happens,
you can figure out
that it happened, talk
to somebody, and help
get it fixed.
Now, the key around this
is for the security teams
to work closely with
the development teams
to make sure that they are
viewed as an enabler and not
as a block.
In terms of the core Forseti
modules, what we offer
are a couple of things.
First is inventory.
So the inventory module
allows you, as a customer,
to get a good snapshot
of all of the resources
that are running inside
of your GCP environment.
The first step is visibility.
Once you see those different
resources that are there,
you can then scan
those resources using
the scanning module and
understand if any of them
are not configured
the way that you
would want to, but especially
from a policy perspective.
So you might want to
be able to say things
like, I don't want anybody
from outside of my domain
to be a project editor on
this particular project.
Once that scanning
piece finds something,
it can then send
off a notification
either to you via email,
to a Slack channel.
It can also connect into our
Cloud Security Command Center
to give you a violation
warning there as well.
And Michael will show
you a little bit more
about that later in
the demonstration.
The third piece that we've
got is an enforcement module.
And what that does is it
says, hey, this person
has done something that we
think is so bad that not only
do we want to alert
somebody about it,
we're going to roll that back.
An example of this is
around firewall rules,
where you might want to do
that it somebody's opened up
a firewall to 000.
You might want to be able to
roll that back right away.
And then finally, we have a
new module called Explain.
And what that does is
actually really cool.
What it lets you do is
answer your questions like,
who has access--
what access to which resources
inside of my GCP environment?
And that can be a
trickier question
to answer than you might think
when you've talked about things
like nested groups
or the ability
to act as service accounts.
And we'll see a demo of
that later on today as well.
I thought it would be
interesting to tell you
a little bit about how
we started this project.
Inside of Google,
we have a whole team
that is dedicated to helping
secure Google's use on Google
Cloud Platform.
And this team had
built a set of tools
that was really interesting
and that we were really looking
for help to extend and expand.
And we thought that the
work that we had done
could be a really great
catalyst for our customers
to build upon.
And so as we started to
reach outside of Google
to see who might be interested
in participating with us
and helping us build
out this set of tooling,
we found Spotify.
And Spotify was in the
midst of their own journey
on migrating into
GCP, and they were
thinking about this sort
of same set of problems.
How do you set up good
guardrails for people
so that you let them move
fast but get notified
when something goes wrong?
And so as we started to
collaborate together on this--
it was almost a year ago that
we started working together
and announced this
collaboration.
Over the past year,
we've grown the number
of companies that contribute
to and help maintain Forseti.
And we're really looking
for more people to do that.
We think that contributing
lets you share your expertise
and really helps the entire
ecosystem get safer across GCP.
It's really been an
amazing experience
to have all of us working
together to create a safer
environment on GCP.
And what I'd really like
to do is invite Michael
from Two Sigma to come
up and tell us a little
about his experience
doing that and show you
a little bit about some of
the work that he's done.
So please welcome
Michael Capicotto.
MICHAEL CAPICOTTO:
Thanks, Chris.
CHRIS LAW: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL CAPICOTTO: All right,
thanks, everyone, for joining.
Hope you all enjoyed your
time last night at the party.
So let me first
introduce Two Sigma.
Two Sigma is a New
York City-based hedge
fund that really uses
the latest technologies,
artificial intelligence,
machine learning,
distributed computing to drive
their investment decisions.
To give you an example of
the scale that we operate on,
today we have over
35 petabytes of data,
and we use this to
build investment models.
And this number is
growing every day.
So of course, the public
cloud is a very attractive
environment to operate in,
because it gives us the ability
to scale up and scale
down very rapidly based
on whatever kind of computing
and storage demands we have.
And this is super important
from a security perspective,
because our job is to ensure
that all of the code and data
that we have, which is obviously
very private and sensitive,
doesn't leak.
And so data exfiltration is
kind of the primary concern
for the Cloud security team.
So I'm going to switch over
to my laptop for the beginning
part of a demo, so
everyone cross your fingers
and hope the demo
goes well today.
So I wanted to demonstrate like
a couple components of Forseti.
We've been using
Forseti quite heavily
to protect our environment.
And what I'm going
to show you later
is how you can use the
Explain module of Forseti
to kind of unravel why
a particular user has
a permission that they
really shouldn't have.
So to kind of make that happen,
what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to show you how
we've set up some groups.
So we've got this group
called Security Reviewer.
And it has two nested
groups inside of it.
So you can see here, it's
got the Cloud Security
group and an Incident
Response group,
and you can imagine
these are two
separate kind of sub-security
teams in the organization.
And if we dive into the
Cloud Security group--
oh, wrong one.
OK, so my Back button
does not want to work.
What we're going to do is we're
going to dive into the Cloud
Security group, and we're going
to add an unauthorized user.
So kind of the use case that
I'm trying to paint here--
imagine someone joins
the organization.
We're going to go ahead and
create a new user, someone
that just joined today.
And we're going to call
them Very Bad User.
That way they're easy
to identify later on.
And they will be
verybaduser@dev.twosigma.cloud.
So I'll create that user.
Awesome.
Done.
And now, I'm going to add them
to the Cloud Security group.
Now, let's pretend this
person is totally not supposed
to be part of the
Cloud Security group.
They're just getting added
by mistake right now.
And I'm going to show you
how we can use Forseti
to kind of detect that
they're in the wrong group
and then also
understand why they
have a certain
set of permissions
and how we can fix that.
So right now, I'm the
only person in this group,
hopefully, if I've
set this up correctly.
Awesome.
So I'm there.
We're going to
add Very Bad User.
And then what we're
going to do is--
what would happen in practice
is this user would get added,
and Forseti would be taking
an inventory every hour
or something like that.
But obviously, we don't
want to wait an hour.
So I'm going to pop
over here, and I'm just
going to tell Forseti to
create a new inventory that's
now going to include that user.
All right, so we'll switch
back to the slides now.
This is going to take
several minutes to run.
And so while that's
running, I kind of
wanted to explain
the approach we
take to preventing data
exfiltration or data leakage.
So the first thing
that we really
like to do in our environments
is practice strong defense
in depth.
What I mean by this is kind
of using a layered approach
to security-- so if you think
about your GCP organization,
using things like org policies
all the way up at the top level
to prevent certain things
that you don't want to happen
across your entire org.
So an example of
this is imagine you
have a team that
builds images that you
want to launch VMs from, and
they harden those images.
They build any sort of
monitoring and logging
components into them
that you'd like to have.
And now, you want to ensure
that your entire environment,
your entire organization only
builds VMs from that image,
so you can use an org
policy to accomplish this.
So that's kind of the
top-level approach.
But then, you're going to
have more specific needs
when you dive down into the
individual project and folder
level.
So for that, we have
individual IAM policies,
custom admin roles
that we create
in the folders and projects.
And the reason we use
those custom roles
is because we really like
to scope users and groups
to a minimum set of permissions.
Whatever the smallest
amount of permissions
they need to do
their job is really
how we like to handle things.
And then if you think about
diving down even deeper,
things like resource
access control lists,
so on a BigQuery set
or on a GCS bucket,
you can have access control
lists at the individual bucket
level.
And so using this kind
of layered approach
is very important to us.
Because it means if we make
a mistake or something goes
wrong in one of those
layers, we still
have some other layers
to fall back on.
And of course, we
accomplish that
by using pretty
heavy automation.
So our team, the
Cloud security team,
tries to take an
automate first approach.
So anything that we do in
the kind of public cloud,
we always try to build through
some sort of automation
pipeline if we can.
I'm going to show you a
couple examples of this,
so I won't talk about
it too much now.
And then, of course, we have
the continuous audit piece.
So this is important
not at the beginning
of the environment's inception
but as the environment ages.
So defense and depth is like the
overall strategy that you take,
and automation is how you
deploy the environment.
But things are constantly
changing in the public Cloud.
There's changes that Google
makes to their services.
As your users are
interacting with resources,
they make changes as well.
And so you can't be 100%
certain that if you set up
the environment in
a secure way, it's
going to stay like that forever.
And so you need
some sort of system
to of continuously audit
and check your environment
and then notify you if
something goes wrong.
And that's really what we use
Forseti and Cloud Security
Command Center for.
I wanted to just
take a sidestep,
and this kind of
relates to the demo.
But I wanted to show a
couple examples of automation
that we use at Two Sigma.
So we have users that
want to, for example,
create a BigQuery dataset.
And quick show of hands-- how
many people in the audience
know what permission you
get on the BigQuery dataset
ACL if you're the
creator of that dataset.
Oh, I see a couple people
from Two Sigma there
raising their hands.
[LAUGHTER]
That's not fair.
OK, so what happens?
When you create a
BigQuery dataset,
you become owner on the ACL.
And the effect
that that has is it
lets you share that
dataset with anyone,
even users outside
your organization.
So of course, from a
security perspective,
this is not great, because if
you're loading sensitive data
into that dataset,
you don't want
that to be shareable
with the entire world.
So what we've done here is
we've created a special Cloud
Function.
So it's kind of completely
serverless and hands-off
from an operational perspective.
And what the Cloud Function does
is the user, rather than making
a gcloud command to
create a BigQuery dataset,
they make a gcloud command
to the Cloud Function.
And what the Cloud Function
does is it goes and creates
the BigQuery dataset.
And it fixes the
ACL on the resource
so that no one is
the owner of it.
There's only editors.
And then it just returns
a response to the user.
So another kind of example
along the very similar vein
is the use case we came
across for developers
who want to spin
up VMs, and they
want to attach a service
account to those VMs.
So they need to be able
to create those service
accounts on demand.
They can't wait for
someone from my team
to go and create service
accounts for them
every time they need a new VM.
But the problem is
a service account
is kind of useless unless it
has permissions attached to it
or a role attached to it.
And there's a special
permission you
need in a project to attach
a service account to a role.
And when you give
someone that permission,
they can attach any role
to any service account.
This is, again, not great
from a security perspective.
Because even though they
might promise you, hey,
we're only going to attach
the GCS viewer role,
they might go ahead and attach
the project owner or something
like that, which is
quite a gaping security
hole if you let that happen.
So again, we've abstracted that
away with the Cloud Function.
And what we've done is we just
let the user supply the service
account name, and
the Cloud Function
will actually link the service
account to a predefined role.
That way, the user doesn't
have control over that,
but they still have
the automation in place
to deploy it.
And this example
is kind of what I'm
going to demonstrate to you.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to show how someone
got the ability
to do this without using
the Cloud Function,
just do it directly.
And we're going to uncover how
they inherited that permission.
So I spoke a little bit
about defense in depth
and how we use various layers
of security in the organization.
I also spoke about
the automation piece
with those two Cloud Functions.
And I want to talk now
a little bit about how
we use Forseti in conjunction
with Cloud Security Command
Center.
Quick show of hands-- who knows
what Cloud Security Command
Center is?
Wicked.
OK, awesome.
So Cloud Security
Command Center,
for those of you who
don't know, is really
like a inventory and
dashboard in the GCP console
but used strictly for
security-related things right.
So you can think of it as
your security landing page,
and I'll show you guys what that
looks like in a few minutes.
But what we do is we have
various sources of security
information, one of them being
Forseti, other ones being
custom code that we write.
They could be
third-party products
like a firewall or something or
a logging service that you use.
And what we do is
we bubble up all
of those kind of security
findings into Cloud Security
Command Center.
So one of the coolest
pieces of Forseti
is the scanner component.
The scanner component
lets you write
rules in a very
simple YAML format
that you want your
environment to adhere to.
And once those
rules are written,
you supply them to
the Forseti service.
And every time it runs
an inventory creation
and a new model is
created, it's also
going to check all of your rules
to make sure if any of them--
to see if any of them
have been violated.
And if they are, you can get
notified, like Chris said,
in various ways.
Or you can get an
email if that's
like how you want to do things.
You can get a
notification on Slack.
I know that's being worked on.
And also a Pub/Sub notification
is being worked on.
But the way we do
it is we basically
create a finding in Cloud
Security Command Center
so that our incident response
team can go and act on that.
And these are what
the rules look like.
So this example
here basically shows
something that relates to the
first example I showed you
with the BigQuery dataset.
So this basically
says that only--
and I guess I can try to--
oh, I can't highlight it.
But if you look at the
bottom of the screen there,
you'll see the service
account, proj@appspot.gse
rviceaccount.com.
That is the service account that
is tied to the Cloud Function
that we use for automation.
And what this rule is
saying is make sure
that the only entity, or
the only service account,
that has a specific role
to create BigQuery datasets
is that service account
used by the Cloud Function.
So it's essentially a waitlist,
and if it finds any other user
group or service account
with that TS.CreateDataset
role, which is a custom
role we've created,
it will notify us.
So we'll create a finding in
Cloud Security Command Center.
Another way to approach this--
again, defense in depth.
We don't like to just
put one rule in place
and rely heavily on that.
So we also check the inverse.
Rather than checking who has
permission to create datasets,
we also want to say if
anyone ever shows up
in the dataset ACL that has an
@twosigma.com email address,
please notify us of that,
because there really shouldn't
be anyone in that dataset ACL.
And this is very similar
to the first one.
So again, it's a very
straightforward thing
saying the service account
used by the Cloud Function
should be the only thing that
can do the binding of service
account to admin role.
So that's another customer
role we've created
there, TS.BindService Account.
Oh yeah, and I wanted
to talk a little bit
about how that integration
actually happens.
So Forseti Scanner runs.
It finds violations
to the rules.
And now, it wants to
notify you about them.
And to get the violations into
Cloud Security Command Center,
there was existing
integration before we
started using the two products.
And the way that
integration worked
is you essentially
had a GCS bucket.
Forseti would run.
It would create a
list of violations
in a specific format, and
it would dump that to GCS.
And then, Cloud
Security Command Center
would wake up every
so often, and it
would read the GCS bucket
and create a list of findings
based on the violations
in the bucket.
But we kind of felt that
this was a little bit clunky
and that it could be better,
because Cloud Security Command
Center is kind of
in alpha right now.
And eventually,
they exposed an API,
so you could write findings
directly via the API.
And I really want to give
a shout out to Forseti
team because, we
really chose to use
Forseti as our main
security tool--
main security monitoring tool
in GCP because it's open source
and because it's so
easy to work with.
So when we saw this kind of--
I don't want to call it a
deficiency but just something
that could be improved,
we got in touch
with Chris and the Forseti team.
And we basically said, look,
like can we transform this?
And they were like,
yeah, for sure.
Let's work on it together.
So we wrote some
very simple code
at first, which became a
little bit more complex as time
went on.
And then we just
pushed that change
into the Forseti 2.0 branch.
So now there's direct
integration between the two.
So for those of you
who are using Forseti,
if you look in your
configuration file, which
is just the AML file that
you use to set up Forseti,
you'll see now that you can
set the CSCC integration
to either GCS mode or API mode.
And if you set it to
API mode, then you're
going to have that
direct integration.
And we really did this because
we felt it was faster, cleaner,
and it gives you
a lot more control
over the properties that
you write into your findings
in Cloud Security
Command Center.
So if you have very
specific rules, like we do,
that the scanner is running,
you can control exactly what
information about
each of those rules
gets written into the
security command center.
All right, so I can
see that my inventory
creation is done here, so
let's switch over to the demo.
Awesome.
So the first thing we're
going to do is just make sure
that the inventory
creation was successful.
And we can see here that
probably about 12 minutes ago,
the inventory creation finished.
And so once you've taken
an inventory in Forseti,
the next step is to create
a model from that inventory.
And the model lets
you ask questions
about all the information you
collected in the inventory.
So we're going to do
Forseti model create.
And we're going to
specify this inventory,
and we're going to
call it superduperdemo.
Hopefully, I have not used
that word before here.
Otherwise, it will fail.
And so this will take
about 30 seconds I think.
And essentially
what it's doing is
it's collecting all of the
attributes and the resources
that the inventory collect,
and it's creating a model.
And the model is going to let us
ask some really cool questions.
So let me kind of
paint a picture now.
Imagine your incident response
team comes in Thursday morning.
Today's Thursday.
And they get this alert.
So this is the Cloud Security
Command Center Dashboard,
and I've created this
project called Demo.
You can see it here as an asset.
And imagine your incident
response team comes in,
and they see this finding here.
So this is probably
not a good thing.
It's probably something
you want to investigate.
So if I dive into
that finding, it
says unauthorized
permission detected.
It's from 10:01 last night.
So it looks like what
happened is someone didn't
get enough work done this week.
And after the
Chainsmokers concert
in their cab ride on the
way back to their hotel,
they tried to do some work.
And clearly, they
made a mistake,
because now, there's
unauthorized permission.
So we're going to dive into that
finding and see what it says.
So it says that the
source is Forseti.
So it means that we're
doing our job properly,
and Forseti's picked
up some information.
We've got details here.
It says
verybaduser@dev.twosigma.cloud
was found with
elevated permissions.
And so the first thing
you would probably
do as a security practitioner
is you would go to that project,
and you would dive
into the IAM console.
And you would try to find
out why that person has
those permissions.
So let's take a look at that.
So this is the demo project.
You can see that up here.
And the permission
we care about is
the one that allows you to link
a service account to a role.
And that permission
is contained--
I can show you right here--
in this project IAM admin role.
So it's actually this
permission right here.
It's called resourcemanager.
projects.setIampolicy.
It allows you to
create that binding.
But the interesting
thing is that we
can see right here the only
person in the demo project,
or only group in the demo
project, with that permission
is security reviewer.
And so it would be very
difficult at this point
for someone to kind
of investigate,
because you can't click this
group here and see who's in it.
And you can't expand out
all the nested groups.
It might be pretty
trivial for us to do that,
because I just
have a small group.
But you can imagine having
groups of hundreds or thousands
of users.
It's very difficult
to inspect that.
So Forseti's going to
make that easier for us,
and I'll show you how.
So the model is created.
So I'm just going to
say, Forseti study model
use superduperdemo.
Cool.
And now, we can ask questions
about this using the explainer
module.
So I'm going to walk
you guys through this
before I run it, but
basically what it says--
let me zoom in, so
everyone can see that.
That's better.
So essentially what
it says is that we
want to know why a specific
permission was granted.
The user is
verybaduset@dev.twosigma.com.
And the resource is the project,
that demo project I showed you.
And we're asking about a
very specific permission,
which is the resourcemanager.
projects.setIamPolicy.
Awesome.
So let me actually zoom out now,
so we can see what's going on.
Cool.
So what Forseti has
done here is it's
used that model we
created, and it's
unpacked and unrolled and
flattened out all of the groups
and their subgroups.
And so we can see here
that Very Bad User is
part of a group
called Cloud Security,
and Cloud Security has a parent
group called Security Reviewer.
And it's actually taken
things a step further,
and it's showing us that
Security Reviewer has
this role, Project IAM
Admin, in the demo project.
So as opposed to having to go
and click through the console
and expand all the groups and
kind of scroll through them
and search through them,
we've used the Explain module
of Forseti to just
very quickly see
why the user has a
certain permission.
Another thing that we could do--
I've got a little script here.
We could look at things
from a different angle.
So what we could do is say
Forseti explainer access
by resource.
So rather than looking
at what permissions
a particular user has,
we're going to say,
show me all the permissions
for a particular resource.
So this can be super powerful.
And I'm just going to
copy the rest of it.
This is probably going to
run for another 30 seconds,
but basically, I think
this is really powerful,
because what it
allows you to do is
pick a particular resource
or a particular user
in your environment and say,
show me all the permissions
that that user has, or
show me all the users
or groups or service
accounts that have access
to that resource.
And this can be
very powerful from
an investigative perspective.
So hopefully, this
finishes up soon,
and I can actually dive
into it and show you
guys what that looks like.
We'll cross our fingers.
And I guess those are
not the only two things.
Maybe I'm
oversimplifying it here.
There's also the
inverse to why granted.
So you see this
why granted here,
which is the first one I ran.
There's also a why not
granted or why blocked.
So this is really
useful for our team,
because I'm sure of all
the security people here--
kind of give me a show
of hands if this has ever
happened to you.
You get a team coming to you
saying, we need project owner.
And you're like no, no, no.
You can't have project owner.
You've got to have like a
minimum set of permissions.
So they come up with some
minimum set of permissions,
and you grant it to them.
And 30 seconds later, they
come back to your desk,
and they're like, yeah, I
can't do what I want to do.
I'm blocked.
How many people has
that happened to?
Awesome.
OK.
And that's super painful.
That sucks.
So this allows you to not
go back and forth with them
a million times.
You can just run a
simple command that
says, why was this user
not allowed to do this,
not allowed to
make this API call.
And Forseti will tell
you right away what
permission they're missing.
All right, so that's done.
So we can look at the
project permissions now.
And you can see like a whole
bunch of stuff in here,
but really what we're
looking for is that--
what was it-- resource manager.
And there are a lot
of them in here.
Oh, cool, it was the
previous one there.
Let me just scroll up.
So anyway, this is
basically a list
of bindings in the project,
but you can see here the one
that we care about.
So what this has
actually done is it said
for the project/ts-dev-demo
and the role project IAM admin,
unpack all the groups and
flatten them and tell me
everyone has that permission.
So it's really just
another way to look at it.
All right, so that
concludes the demo.
Let's go back to the slides.
I think that's all I have.
So I'd like to invite
Marten van Wezel up
on stage, a product
manager for Forseti,
to talk to you about kind
of the future of Forseti.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
MARTEN VAN WEZEL:
Thanks, Michael.
That was cool.
Hey, everyone.
My name is Martin, and I'm a
product manager on Forseti.
As the last section
of today, I would
like to talk to you about
where we are right now
and where we're
going in the future.
So as some of you
might know, on July 16,
we launched what is
called for Forseti 2.0.
And that was the
culmination of a lot
of work, a lot of testing
not just by us but also
by a bunch of customers,
including Michael's team,
on how it worked.
And we did a lot of work
on listening to our users.
I've spoken to many, many
people about what they needed.
And we've tried to
address what they
wanted as much as we could.
And it's an ongoing
procedure, of course,
but 2.0 marks a
very nice milestone
where we've made things
quite easy to install,
made things faster or more
consistent and understandable
from a code perspective, from
a documentation perspective.
But I called it a milestone, and
that is for a specific reason.
We want to, at this
point, shift gears
and take things in a bit of a
slightly different direction.
And this new direction
that we're thinking about
has three pillars.
We want to provide you,
the user, developers
and just security admins,
with the tools and the team
to build on top of Forseti.
So that means that we want
you to tell us what you need.
We'll help you get there.
And we'll also
want to collaborate
in the entire community
on working out
which are the best
practices in security
that we want to think about
and then, perhaps, encode them
into Forseti and check for them.
So let me go in a
bit of more detail.
First of all, like I said,
a foundation to build on--
so for us, that means
that our core team wants
to focus a lot on making
Forseti even more stable,
understandable, rugged, all
these kind of good words
that enable people,
like yourself,
to build on top of this easily.
And of course, that
includes documentation
and all kinds of
connectivity, connection
to external products, Pub/Sub
was mentioned, and so forth.
Second pillar here is community.
And that is really the
most important one for us
at this point, which is
that you are now in focus.
We want to extend the
way we reach out to you--
and we'll speak a little bit
about that-- but basically,
extend how you feel
that you can talk
to us and also hopefully to
other people in that community.
And for that reason,
what we're going to do is
we're-- we've been
working on things,
like governance documents,
rules of the road, and so forth.
And we don't
pretend that we know
everything there is to know.
So we're not going to do
this in the this is it, done,
deal with it approach.
What we want to do,
and what we will do,
is probably even do rules
as code by just showing you
our documentation
and going, hey, this
is what we thought about.
What do you think?
And let's modify it.
Maybe we'll just put
the rules on GitHub.
Let's see-- and have
you guys suggest changes
and see if you're cool with it.
And the final part
is best practices.
I've been speaking
to customers a ton,
and one thing that
kept on coming up
is that people said, well, this
Forseti, the installation is
pretty efficient at this point.
But once it's
done, still there's
a lot of track to cover
before you get something
useful out Forseti, before
it tells me something
that I can do with
not too much noise,
that I know what to
do next and so forth,
and that the rules make
sense for my architecture.
So that's a lot of stuff
that we need to cover.
And the way we want to
do that is not just sort
of write things
down but really try
to source a bunch of
these rules, things that
work for you, you, and
you; things that came out
of the Google professional
services organization;
things that came from
Google eng themselves,
and try to discuss those
rules, collate them, figure out
which ones make sense, maybe
divide them up into verticals.
Like maybe financial people have
totally different requirements
than people in commerce.
So what we want to do
is start a discussion,
figure out which
rules are there,
and then start to
effectively see, hey,
can we encode these in Forseti?
Does current Forseti support it?
If not, let's start building.
And we will help you with that.
So as an example a
good best practice
that we haven't implemented
yet but we really
want to do very badly
is policy as code.
And you've heard the words
mentioned before, perhaps,
but one key thing
we want to say there
is that we want to move
Forseti a little bit
forward in your CI/CD chain.
And before the
architecture is even there,
when it's only, let's
say, a terreform plan
or something that's sitting
in your deployment manager,
run Forseti on that
and go, hey, do
you think this will make sense?
Or will we have problems later?
So that's something
that we really
want to focus on very soon.
So to round this all off, we
want to enable the community--
and we are, as much as you,
part of that community--
to make sure that
Forseti works for you
and enable you to
build on top of it,
so expand it in every way that
makes sense for your future
and for your security.
[MUSIC PLAYING]